supongamos que queremos evaluar el
límite el límite de cuando x tiende a
cero de la siguiente expresión de dos
veces seno de dos veces de x menos seno
de 2x y todo eso dividido entre eso
dividido entre x menos seno de x ahora
la primera cosa que yo siempre hago
cuando tengo un problema de límites es
intentar ver qué pasa si evaluamos con x
igual a cero vamos a ver qué sucede
porque con un poco de suerte no pasa
nada muy loco vamos a intentarlo si
intentamos hacer x igual a cero en esta
expresión en el numerador tenemos dos
veces seno de cero que es un cero menos
seno de dos veces cero entonces queda
seno de cero otra vez entonces tenemos
un numerador igual a cero sequemos seno
de cero es cero seno de dos veces cero
es cero entonces otro cero todo eso de
aire cero y en el denominador tenemos un
cero menos seno de cero eso es otro cero
y entonces ya encontramos una forma
indeterminada para la regla del hopital
es una forma 0 entre 0 de la que
hablamos en el vídeo pasado entonces tal
vez con un poco de suerte podamos
utilizar la regla del hopital vamos a
recordar lo que nos dice esta regla nos
dice que si este límite de que existiera
entonces debe ser igual al límite de la
derivada del numerador entre la derivada
del denominador entonces vamos a
intentar hacer esto para ver si nos
lleva a algún lugar entonces lo voy a
hacer aquí abajo
esta cosa suponiendo que existe va a ser
igual al al límite de cuando x tiende a
0 de la derivada del numerador entonces
vamos a hacer eso voy a hacer la
derivada con color con color verde
entonces vamos a hacerlo aquí abajito la
derivada de 12 no de x es dos veces
coseno de x dos coseno de x y luego
tenemos que restar la derivada desde
seno de 2x
qué es dos veces cosenos de 2x menos dos
veces coseno de 2 x ay usamos la regla
de la cadena la derivada de adentro es 2
ahí está el 2 la derivada de lo de
afuera es coseno el valor de lo de
adentro es cosa de 2x entonces la
derivada del numerador y para el
denominador tenemos que derivar también
la derivada de x es 1 la derivada de
seno de x es cosa no de x es uno menos
coseno de x entonces vamos a intentar
evaluar este límite para ver que tenemos
vamos a ver qué obtenemos si ponemos un
cero aquí arriba tenemos dos x coseno de
cero que es 2 a verlo voy a escribir así
es 2 x cosas no es 0 que es uno es dos
menos dos veces coseno de dos veces cero
coseno de haberlo escribir mejor aquí a
la derecha para que quede un poco más
claro lo que estamos haciendo entonces
tenemos una cosa del estilo dos veces
coseno es cero que es dos menos dos
veces coseno de dos veces cero entonces
otra vez coseno de cero entonces es otra
vez un 2
y eso hay que dividirlo entre entre este
uno pasa directo lo ponemos así uno
menos el coseno de cero que es uno
entonces una vez más obtenemos una forma
del estilo cero entre cero tenemos una
cosa del estilo cero entre cero y esto
que quiere decir que el límite no existe
claro que no todavía podría existir
simplemente puede ser que tengamos que
usar la regla del hopital una vez más
voy a derivar una vez más el numerador y
el denominador y tomar el límite y a ver
qué pasa entonces vamos a ver qué sucede
si derivamos si el límite existe si la
regla del hopital aplicará el límite
tendría que ser igual al límite de
cuando x tiende a cero de la derivada
del numerador del nuevo numerador entre
la derivada del denominador la derivada
de 2 kos en x la derivada de coseno de x
es menos seno de x entonces obtenemos
menos dos veces seno de x y la derivada
de coseno de 2x es menos dos veces senos
de 2 x x este menos se hace más con el 2
de aquí se hace un 4 entonces nos va a
quedar más cuatro veces seno de 2x
déjame checar si lo hicimos bien
entonces es un -2 multiplicado por la
derivada de coseno de 2x usando regla de
la cadena esto es 2x menos seno de 2 x 2
x 2 de 4 el menos por el menos se
convierte en un más y tenemos un seno de
2x entonces el numerador cuando lo
derivamos que de esta cosa y en el
denominador va a otra derivada y para
cómo vamos esto ya parece más bien un
ejercicio de derivadas bueno derivada de
10 derivada de menos coseno de x estreno
de x entonces ya ponemos seno de x
entonces vamos a intentar hacer este
límite vamos a evaluar x igual a 0 a ver
qué sucede entonces este seno de 0 daba
a 0 en el numerador menos 2 por seno de
0 va tercero y cuatro veces seno de dos
veces 000 otra vez
que se nos dé ser otra vez puros ceros
entonces una vez más tenemos cero entre
cero ya terminamos nos rendimos ya no
funcionó el hospital claro que no
todavía podemos pensar que este fue el
problema inicial y entonces ahí tenemos
que pensar verdad cambiar la mentalidad
y decir otra vez podemos usarlo hospital
tenemos una forma cero entre cero y pues
vamos a derivar una vez más vamos a
derivar una vez más a ver qué pasa si el
límite existe esto debería ser igual al
límite cuando x tiende a cero vamos a
derivar el numerador el numerador de
menos dos veces seno de x es menos 2
coseno de equis y luego hay que sumar la
derivada de cuatro veces seno de 2x
entonces es dos veces por cuatro es ocho
veces coseno de 2x verdad la derivada de
seno de 2x es dos veces
coseno de 2 x x el 4 se convierte en 18
y luego la derivada del denominador la
derivada del denominador es simplemente
coseno de x verdad es seno de x
derivados
evaluamos aquí me falta una equis parece
ser que ya logramos algo verdad ahora sí
la regla del hopital parecer que ya va a
funcionar porque ahora coseno de x se
hace coseno es 0 que vale 1 ya no vamos
a tener 0 entre 0 lo cual es una señal
de que vamos avanzando un poco más ahora
la derivada del numerador es perdón
evaluando en cero en numeradores menos 2
por cocina es 0 que es menos 2 y hay que
sumar ocho veces coseno de dos veces
cero entonces esto va a ser igual al
coseno de cero es uno se convierte en un
entonces fíjate ahora si menos 2 + 8 es
un 66 entre 16 entonces la regla del
hopital al fin aplicó entonces esta
expresión si pensamos que era el
problema inicial pues ya la aplicamos
l'hospital entonces pues a ver tuvimos
una forma indeterminada derivamos
entonces que el límite de los cocientes
de las derivadas si existe y no sólo
existe sino que además sabemos que es
igual a 6
es fantástico pues la regla de lópez
asegura que el límite de esta otra
expresión también es igual a 6 y más aún
podemos repetir el argumento para ver
que este otro límite también es igual a
6 por lo tanto podemos concluir que el
límite inicial también vale 6 y
terminamos